"Qu'est-ce que la vie? "
C’est la question qu’on s’était posée
dans un épisode précédent,
et j’avais essayé de vous donner
des éléments de réponse
à partir de ce qu’on sait
de la vie sur Terre,
et de son fonctionnement biochimique.
Mais si on essaye d’imaginer ce que pourrait
être une forme de vie extra-terrestre,
il faut peut-être essayer de
réfléchir de façon plus large.
En se basant trop sur la vie telle
qu’on la connait, avec de l’eau,
des molécules à base de carbone,
des cellules
on risque peut-être de passer à côté
de formes de vie très différentes,
basées sur des phénomènes ou des
structures qu’on aurait pas envisagés.
Mais comment trouver une définition
suffisamment large
de ce qu’on pourrait appeler la vie?
Quand la NASA lui avait posé cette question,
le chimiste américain James Lovelock
avait dit "Pour trouver de la vie,
cherchez des réductions d’entropie".
L'entropie, c'est un concept
de thermodynamique
qui a l'inconvénient d'être un peu obscur,
mais l’avantage d’être très générique,
il s'applique à tout un tas de situations.
C'est donc peut-être une bonne piste
pour essayer de définir la vie
de la façon la plus large possible.
Dans cet épisode, on va donc s'intéresser
à une approche thermodynamique
de ce qu'est la vie,
en utilisant notamment
une proposition récente
qui a eu un certain écho,
et qui nous vient de l’astrobiologiste
Stuart Bartlett, qui travaille à Caltech.
Pour éviter d'être trop influencé
par ce qu’on a autour de nous,
Bartlett a d’abord suggéré que
le terme "vie", life en anglais,
soit réservé à la vie sur Terre
telle qu’on la connait.
Et il a proposé l'utilisation
d'un nouveau terme "lyfe avec y »,
il le prononce "loyfe", pour
désigner la vie au sens large,
tout ce qui a les caractéristiques de la vie,
et qui pourrait exister ailleurs
que sur Terre.
Sa définition s’appuie sur 4 piliers
inspirés par la thermodynamique:
la vie au sens large, la lyfe,
ce serait "des structures dissipatives,
capables d'autocatalyse,
d'homéostasie et d’apprentissage.
À ce stade, ces termes vous paraissent
probablement plutôt obscurs,
et le but de la vidéo ça va être justement
de les décortiquer, de les illustrer,
et de voir en quoi ils pourraient
former une définition raisonnable
pour "la vie au sens large".
[jingle]
Pour être sûr de ne pas rater
une forme de vie très inattendue,
James Lovelock avait donc conseillé
de rechercher des endroits
présentant des réductions d'entropie.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire?
L'entropie, c'est une notion
de thermodynamique
qu'on associe souvent à l'idée de désordre.
Prenez des billes rouges et bleues
rangées dans une boite.
Si vous avez toutes les rouges d'un côté
et toutes les bleues de l'autre,
l'entropie du système est faible.
Si tout est mélangé, l'entropie est élevée.
Or si on regarde les êtres vivants
tels qu’on les connait,
ce sont plutôt des structures super complexes
et extrêmement bien ordonnées.
Prenons par exemple un léopard:
c'est un système bien plus organisé
que ce qu’on obtiendrait
si on mélangeait aléatoirement
toutes les molécules qui le composent.
La vie, c’est un peu le contraire du désordre.
Les êtres vivants sont des systèmes
de faible entropie.
Ce qui est bizarre,
c'est qu'il existe une loi en physique
qui dit que l'entropie ne peut qu'augmenter.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le second principe
de la thermodynamique.
Globalement, l'Univers doit tendre
vers le désordre.
Manifestement, le développement
de la vie fait tout l'opposé de ça:
on a de plus en plus d’ordre et de structure.
Alors est-ce que la vie viole le second
principe de la thermodynamique?
Est-ce que c’est ça la définition de
la vie: un truc un peu magique
qui a le pouvoir de s'affranchir
d'une loi physique fondamentale?
Eh bien non, cet apparent paradoxe
avait déjà été soulevé et expliqué
par le physicien Erwin Schrödinger en 1944,
dans un essai intitulé "What is life? ".
Et pour comprendre pourquoi la vie ne
va pas à l'encontre de la thermodynamique,
il faut regarder les choses de plus près.
En thermodynamique, il y a deux quantités
fondamentales: l'énergie et l'entropie.
Pour les curieux j’avais déjà fait
une vidéo spécifique sur le sujet,
mais je vais expliquer les grandes lignes.
L’énergie, on sait qu'elle peut exister
sous différentes formes:
l'énergie cinétique quand un objet
est en mouvement,
l'énergie thermique, quand il est chaud,
l'énergie potentielle, l'énergie électrique,
l'énergie chimique etc.
Dans un système isolé, la quantité totale
d’énergie est conservée, elle est constante
C’est le premier principe
de la thermodynamique.
Il n’y a pas de création d’énergie,
pas de destruction.
Il est seulement possible de transformer
une forme d'énergie en une autre.
Quand vous pédalez pour recharger
une batterie,
l'énergie est d’abord sous forme chimique,
dans vos muscles,
puis elle est convertie en énergie mécanique,
puis en énergie électrique,
et à nouveau en énergie chimique
dans la batterie.
Avec en plus à chaque étape la
production d’un peu d’énergie thermique.
L’énergie reste en quantité constante,
et ne fait que changer de forme.
Mais malgré cela, toutes les formes
d'énergie ne se valent pas.
En fait il y en a une qui est
moins exploitable que les autres,
c'est l'énergie thermique,
sous forme de chaleur.
Je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails,
mais pour le dire de façon imagée,
c'est une forme d'énergie qui est plus
diluée, moins concentrée,
comme si elle était de moins bonne qualité
que les autres.
Et ça la rend moins utilisable.
Si on représente la quantité totale
d’énergie contenue dans un système
sous la forme d’une barre,
on peut donc distinguer
l’énergie thermique d'un côté, moins utile,
des autres formes d’énergie,
plus concentrées.
On les regroupe sous le terme
d’énergie libre.
Et le premier principe de la thermodynamique
nous dit donc que, pour un système isolé,
la taille de la barre ne change pas,
l’énergie totale est conservée.
Bien, passons à l’entropie.
Tout à l’heure, je vous ai dit qu’elle pouvait
se voir comme une mesure du désordre.
Eh bien voici une autre manière de la définir.
L’entropie d’un système mesure
en quelque sorte
la quantité d’énergie inutile qu’il contient.
Ici on a un système d’entropie faible,
beaucoup d’énergie libre,
peu d’énergie thermique.
Et ici un système d’entropie élevée,
c’est l’inverse.
L’entropie quantifie en quelque sorte
la qualité de l’énergie d’un système.
Et ce que nous dit le second
principe de la thermodynamique,
c’est que dans un système isolé,
l’entropie ne peut qu’augmenter.
Ca veut dire que de l'énergie libre
peut spontanément se convertir
en énergie thermique,
mais ça ne va jamais dans l'autre sens.
La qualité de l’énergie
ne peut que se dégrader.
Donc dans le langage courant,
quand on parle de consommer
de l'énergie pour faire quelque chose,
en pratique, ce qu'on consomme c'est de
l'énergie libre.
On augmente l'entropie, on diminue
la part d'énergie libre.
On appelle cela de la dissipation d’énergie.
Dans un système, cela peut parfois se produire
de façon spontanée,
et dans ce cas, le système va évoluer
vers un état d’entropie maximale
qu’on appelle l’équilibre thermodynamique.
A l’équilibre thermodynamique,
le système est homogène,
et ses caractéristiques macroscopiques
ne varient plus.
C’est par exemple ce qu’il se passe si on
dépose une goutte d'encre dans un verre d'eau,
l'encre va se diluer, se répartir
dans le verre,
et tendre vers un état d'équilibre
où la concentration d'encre
est la même dans tout le verre.
Cette idée d’évolution vers
l’équilibre thermodynamique
semble être en contradiction flagrante
avec le phénomène de la vie.
Comment un arbre, par exemple,
pourrait croitre
et devenir de plus en plus
complexe et structuré,
si la thermodynamique nous dit
qu'il devrait forcément évoluer vers
le désordre et l'homogénéité?
Eh bien ce qui permet de résoudre cet
apparent paradoxe,
c'est un petit détail que j'ai mentionné
vite fait mais qui est essentiel:
les principes de la thermodynamique
s'appliquent quand un système est isolé.
Isolé ça veut dire qu'il n'échange ni chaleur,
ni forces, ni matière avec son environnement.
Un arbre, un être vivant en général,
même une simple cellule,
c'est tout le contraire,
ils ont plein d'échanges
d'énergie ou de matière avec l'extérieur,
ce ne sont pas des systèmes isolés.
On dit qu’il s’agit de systèmes ouvert.
Et un système ouvert ne va pas
forcément tendre
vers un état d'équilibre et d'entropie
maximale.
Il peut parfaitement arriver à se maintenir
dans un état ordonné, de faible entropie,
et loin de l’état d’équilibre thermodynamique.
Pour reprendre mon exemple, pour un léopard,
l’équilibre thermodynamique ce serait l’état
où toutes les molécules qui le composent
sont mélangées aléatoirement en une sorte
de soupe de léopard.
Et là je pense qu’il ne serait plus vivant.
Pour rester loin de l’état d’équilibre,
un être vivant ne viole pas les principes
de la thermodynamique,
il va piocher de l'énergie libre
dans son environnement,
il la dissipe et s'en sert pour baisser son entropie,
se maintenir organisé.
Mais en faisant ça, il augmente
l’entropie de son environnement,
et bien plus qu’il ne baisse la sienne.
Et l’entropie totale augmente donc quand même.
En gros un être vivant profite de l'énergie
libre disponible dans son environnement
pour rester organisé à l’intérieur,
tout en mettant le sésordre à l'extérieur.
Il existe un terme pour les systèmes
qui se comportent de cette façon:
on les appelle des structures dissipatives.
C’est un concept avancé de thermodynamique,
qui a été introduit et étudié
par le chimiste belge Ilya Prigogine,
qui a d'ailleurs reçu le prix Nobel
de chimie en 1977 pour ça.
Alors est-ce que c’est ça la définition
thermodynamique de la vie:
le fait d’être une structure dissipative,
une machine à faire baisser
localement l’entropie?
Mmmh, pas seulement.
L’idée de structures dissipatives
pour qualifier la vie
est extrêmement intéressante
mais insuffisante.
Car des structures dissipatives
qui ne sont pas a priori vivantes,
on en connait plein.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà vu
une de ces lampes,
qu'on appelle des lampes à lave?
Alors ça n'est pas de la lave dedans,
c'est une cire immergée dans un liquide,
et la densité de cette cire diminue
quand on la chauffe.
L’ampoule située en bas va réchauffer la cire,
celle-ci va s'élever sous l'effet
de la poussée d'Archimède,
puis en haut se refroidir,
devenir plus dense et retomber.
Le mouvement qui se produit ainsi
est un exemple de phénomène naturel
assez courant
qu'on appelle la convection
de Rayleigh-Benard.
L'idée est assez générale,
et il n’y a même pas besoin de cire.
Prenez un récipient contenant un liquide
et chauffez le par en-dessous,
comme il se refroidit naturellement
par la surface,
vous allez créer un écart de température
entre le haut et le bas.
Et dans certaines conditions,
à cause de la poussée d'Archimède,
le fluide va se mettre en mouvement
avec des zones où le fluide chaud,
moins dense, monte,
et d'autres où le fluide froid,
plus dense, descend.
Voici une petite simulation que j’ai réalisée
pour vous montrer comment ça se passe.
On a donc un récipient assez large,
et vu de côté.
La couleur représente la température.
Au départ, tout le fluide est blanc,
à température ambiante.
On chauffe par le bas, et on refroidit
par le haut,
et voici ce qu’il finit par se passer.
les parcelles de fluide chaud monte,
le fluide froid descend.
Et le système finit par s’organiser en
formant des zones
où le fluide circule de façon bien définie.
On appelle cela des cellules de convection.
Quand on fait l’expérience dans un récipient,
et qu’on le regarde du dessus,
cela peut donner former un motif de cellules
ayant des structures
plus ou moins hexagonales,
on peut même en voir parfois
dans les casseroles de soupe.
Pourquoi je vous montre ça, c'est très joli
mais quel rapport avec la vie?
Eh bien c’est une structure dissipative.
Un système qui se structure,
s’organise de façon naturelle,
loin de son état d’équilibre thermodynamique,
et fait donc diminuer son entropie.
Et cette diminution ne viole pas
le second principe de la thermodynamique,
car dans le même temps, l’entropie
de l’environnement, elle, augmente.
Ce phénomène là est assez générique
à partir du moment où on a des fluides
il n'est pas limité aux casseroles de soupe.
C'est lui qui est à l'origine
de nombreux phénomènes atmosphériques,
et notamment des tornades et autres ouragans.
Eh oui les ouragans sont aussi
des structures dissipatives.
On a une masse d’air qui n’est pas
du tout à l’équilibre,
et qui profite des écarts de température
extérieures pour maintenir sa structure.
On pourrait dire la même chose de ce qu'on
appelle la grande tache rouge de Jupiter.
Il s'agit d'une tempête anticyclonique géante
que l'on observe en permanence
depuis des siècles.
Elle ne bouge pas trop,
sa taille a un peu varié.
C’est une belle structure dissipative
gigantesque.
Et pourtant est-ce qu'on a envie de dire
que la grande tache rouge
de Jupiter est vivante?
Probablement pas, même si c’est
une structure dissipative.
Manifestement il manque des choses
à notre définition.
On va essayer de comprendre quoi.
Pour ça, on va regarder une
autre structure dissipative
encore plus familière dans notre
environnement: la flamme d'une bougie.
Il s'agit d'une structure organisée, stable,
qui consomme de l'énergie libre
fournie par la cire.
Une flamme n'est pas à l'équilibre
thermodynamique:
sa température n'est pas du tout uniforme,
très chaude en bas, moins chaude en haut.
Et puis il y a des flux de matière:
la cire fond,
remonte dans la mèche par capillarité,
puis s'évapore et brûle.
C'est une structure dissipative,
et ça peut être tentant de la qualifier de
presque vivante.
Et pourtant il lui manque une capacité
qu'on attribue en général aux être vivants:
la capacité à se reproduire.
Mais si au lieu d'une simple flamme
on considère un feu de forêt?
Comme la bougie, le feu de forêt
dissipe de l'énergie
en transformant de l'énergie chimique
en chaleur.
Comme la flamme il semble posséder
une certaine structure interne,
loin de l'équilibre thermodynamique
Mais en plus il a une capacité à s'étendre
et en quelque sorte à se reproduire.
La raison évidemment c'est que si un bout
de bois brûle, il dégage de la chaleur,
qui va pouvoir allumer un bout de bois voisin
et ainsi de suite.
Tant qu'il y a du combustible,
un feu peut s’auto-entretenir et se propager.
En terme techniques, pour désigner cette
capacité à se maintenir et croitre,
on parle d'auto-catalyse.
L’auto-catalyse est une propriété
essentielle de la vie.
Sur Terre, avec la vie telle qu'on la connait,
cela se manifeste par la division cellulaire
et la reproduction.
Ca nous fait donc un second critère important
pour essayer de définir la vie au sens large.
On cherche des structures dissipatives,
capables d’autocatalyse.
Et pourtant un feu de forêt,
on n'a pas vraiment envie de considérer
que c'est vivant.
Une propriété importante qu'il lui manque
c'est la capacité à se stabiliser
et s'autoréguler face à des perturbations
extérieures.
Un feu de forêt, ça brûle à fond et ça finit
par s'éteindre quand il n'y a plus rien.
Ce n'est pas comme si le feu était capable
de réguler sa propre température,
pour brûler plus ou moins vite
en fonction du combustible disponible,
ou s'adapter par exemple à la vitesse
à laquelle les arbres repoussent.
Cette caractéristique essentielle de la vie
qu'il manque au feu de forêt,
on l'appelle l'homéostasie.
Dans votre corps, il existe un certain
nombre de mécanismes régulateurs
qui permettent d'assurer la stabilité
de beaucoup de vos caractéristiques:
votre température interne, le pH,
la concentration des espèces chimiques, etc.
Ces mécanismes permettent d'améliorer
vos chances de survie
en venant essayer de compenser d’éventuelles
perturbations extérieures.
Si il fait trop froid vous tremblez,
si il fait trop chaud vous transpirez.
Or un feu de forêt,
ça ne fait pas preuve d'homéostasie.
Après ce n'est pas de sa faute,
ça reste un système très basique,
avec un seul type de réaction chimique,
la combustion.
Mais est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer
un petit groupe de réactions chimiques
en interactions,
qui permette d'avoir à la fois
une structure dissipative, autocatalytique
et capable d'homéostasie?
Ca nous permettrait de franchir
une troisième marche
vers la définition de la vie au sens large,
la "lyfe".
Pour faire cette investigation,
on pourrait s'amuser à balancer
tout un tas de réactifs chimiques dans
un bocal, et à voir ce qu'il se passe,
en espérant tomber sur un truc qui marche bien.
Mais ça prendrait beaucoup
de temps et de moyens.
Alors une autre façon de procéder,
c'est de recourir
à des simulations numériques.
Pour commencer notre investigation,
essayons de reproduire
avec une simulation, le comportement
d'un feu de forêt.
Imaginons une grande zone de forêt
qu’on va dessiner comme ça,
chaque pixel représente disons,
quelques mètres-carrés,
et l'intensité du vert,
c’est la densité des arbres à cet endroit là.
et la densité varie sur l'ensemble de la zone
Petite remarque en passant: le fait
qu'on utilise comme combustible du bois,
un truc vivant, ne joue aucun rôle là-dedans.
On pourrait faire ça avec une forêt de cire
ou de carton ce serait pareil.
Pour nous c'est juste un combustible.
Bien maintenant on va représenter pour cette
même zone, la carte de la température.
Initialement je vais considérer que toute
la forêt est à température ambiante,
disons 20°C, d’où la couleur bleue partout.
Et on va juste prendre une petite
zone au milieu
qu’on va mettre à plus haute température
pour simuler l’allumage du feu.
Pour l’instant je n’ai pas lancé la simulation,
il ne se passe rien, c’est normal.
Pour que le système évolue, je vais
modéliser une réaction de combustion
qui est: que si la température est
supérieure à un certain seuil, disons 250°C,
le bois va se mettre à brûler
et dégager de la chaleur.
Petite précision: écrite comme ça
"Bois donne chaleur",
ça n'est pas une vraie réaction chimique.
Il manque le dioxygène et les produits
de la réaction comme le CO2.
Mais pour faire simple, on va garder
la réaction sous cette forme.
Pour les curieux,
derrière cette modélisation,
il y a des équations différentielles,
je vous les épargne.
Alors allons-y: j'ai donc chauffé
ma petite zone à 300°C,
je lance la simulation,
c'est parti.
On le voit, la température monte
dans la petite zone, il y a une combustion,
le bois se consume et disparait…
et beh, c'est tout.
Ben oui le feu ne se répand pas car j'ai oublié
un ingrédient essentiel dans la simulation:
le fait que la chaleur se propage.
S'il fait chaud quelque part
ça doit chauffer autour.
Pour cela, je dois ajouter
dans ma simulation
un phénomène qui est
la diffusion de la chaleur.
Pareil, je vous mets
l’équation différentielle,
mais c'est juste pour les amateurs.
Et maintenant si je relance ma simulation
au point de départ avec cet ingrédient,
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe?
Eh bien cette fois ça se propage,
et ça brûle en progressant dans
presque toute la zone de forêt.
Quand le feu est passé quelque part
et que tout a brûlé,
la température fini par retomber.
Jusqu’à ce que que tout se soit éteint.
Super, je sais simuler un feu de forêt.
Alors pourquoi j'ai montré ça?
Eh bien pour vous présenter les deux notions
qui vont nous servir pour toute la suite:
l'idée de réaction et l'idée de diffusion,
qu'on va utiliser pour la chaleur
mais aussi pour les espèces chimiques.
Avec ces deux concepts, réaction et diffusion,
on va pouvoir simuler
tout un tas de systèmes
et voir jusqu'à quel point,
il peuvent reproduire certaines
caractéristiques de la vie.
Pour cela, je voudrais vous présenter
un modèle de réaction-diffusion
qu'on appelle le modèle de Gray-Scott.
Imaginez une certaine zone dans laquelle
je vais faire mes réactions chimiques,
disons comme une boite de Pétri,
ici je la prends de forme rectangulaire.
Pour l’instant c’est noir, il n’y a rien,
mais dedans, je peux balancer
une substance en cliquant avec ma souris.
L’échelle de couleur m’indique
la concentration en chaque point.
Et vous voyez qu’il se passe un
truc: mon espèce chimique diffuse,
elle s’étale, comme une goutte d’encre.
j'ai modélisé la diffusion.
Pour faire une réaction chimique,
je vais utiliser deux espèces:
on va les appeler A et B.
Pour A, c’est simple,
je vais en mettre partout.
Donc avec mon échelle de couleur,
c’est tout jaune.
Et on imagine qu’il y a un mécanisme
qui approvisionne cette substance
de sorte qu’il y en ait toujours.
Par contre pour B,
je ne vais rien mettre initialement.
Et si j’en ajoute à la main,
ça s’étale à cause de la diffusion.
Et j’ai aussi un mécanisme qui fait que B
se dégrade et est éliminé au fur et à mesure.
Pour l’instant il ne se passe
rien d’intéressant.
parce que je n'ai pas mis
de réaction chimique
Et maintenant je vais en ajouter une
entre les deux.
Cette réaction, c’est A + 2B → 3B.
Voilà une réaction qui vous parait
peut-être un peu bizarre.
Déjà elle n’a pas l’air équilibrée,
mais comme pour le bois qui brulait,
ça n’est pas très important pour nous.
Cette réaction nous dit qu'une molécule A
peut se transformer en B
à condition d'être en présence
de deux autres molécules de B.
C’est comme si les molécules de B
étaient capables de convertir un A en B.
Chimiquement on dit que B catalyse
la transformation de A en B.
Et il s’agit donc d’une réaction
autocatalytique:
parce plus il y a de B, plus il y aura de B.
Cette réaction avec des substances
chimiques A et B
dont on ne précise pas ce que c’est,
ça peut vous paraitre complètement artificiel
mais ça ne l'est pas tant que ça.
Cette réaction qu’on appelle
la réaction de Gray-Scott,
c’est une sorte de version un peu abstraite
de certaines réactions bien réelles,
comme la glycolyse, qui joue un rôle pour
fournir de l’énergie aux cellules vivantes.
Donc allons-y pour la simulation.
Je mets plein de A partout,
mais initialement pas de B.
Et ici je vais juste représenter
la concentration de B.
Il n’y a rien, donc rien ne passe,
et maintenant, je vais saupoudrer
du réactif B avec ma souris.
Et regardez.
C'est assez incroyable,
ça diffuse comme tout à l’heure,
mais du fait de la réaction autocatalytique,
on observe l'apparition spontanée
de petites taches
qui sont des zones riches en B.
Et les taches grossissent, se divisent…
et si on attend suffisamment longtemps,
elles finissent par remplir
tout l'espace et se stabiliser.
C'est vraiment important de comprendre
ce qu'on est en train d'observer là:
il n'y a pas de trucage, à aucun moment
dans le code de simulation
j'ai un concept de cellule
ou quoi que ce soit du genre.
J'ai juste pris deux produits chimiques
qui réagissent entre eux,
je les ai balancé et c'est tout.
Réaction et diffusion, et j'obtiens ça:
quelque chose qui ressemble très fort
à des cellules qui se divisent.
D’ailleurs dans la suite je vais appeler ça
"des cellules" pour faire simple,
mais retenez bien que c’est juste un
truc émergent.
Il n’y a pas de paroi ou de membrane
pour les délimiter.
C’est juste une tache d’une espèce chimique.
Ce résultat que je trouve assez incroyable,
il a été obtenu en premier
par le biophysicien John Pearson en 1993.
Il l'a d'abord codé avec une simulation numérique,
comme je viens de le faire.
Mais ensuite avec des collègues, ils ont
réalisé une vraie expérience de chimie,
avec des vrais ingrédients
qui réagissent entre eux.
Et regardez leurs images
qui montrent la comparaison.
Le code couleur est différent du mien,
mais on voit que dans la véritable expérience,
ils ont obtenu un phénomène
exactement analogue
à ce qu’on voit dans la simulation,
des taches qui se divisent.
Cet exemple nous montre très bien
que faire des simulations numériques,
c’est une bonne manière d'explorer
facilement et rapidement
des systèmes complexes
de réactions chimiques.
Ca permet d’essayer de trouver un
ensemble de réactions
qui auraient une dynamique proche
de celle d'un système vivant.
Et ce qu’on voit, c'est qu'avec le modèle
de Gray Scott, qui reste très simple,
deux espèces et une réaction,
c’est déjà un truc super prometteur.
On a un système qui fonctionne
comme une structure dissipative,
autocatalytique et capable
de coloniser une région de l'espace
avec des motifs structurés
qui apparaissent, disparaissent, se divisent.
Et en plus, je peux même
interagir avec la simulation,
si je rajoute ou que je retire du composé B
quelque part, là avec ma souris,
le système réagit et s'adapte.
Regardez,
ça commence à être une forme d'homéostasie:
une stabilité vis-à-vis des perturbations
extérieures.
Alors là pour l'instant, on n'a modélisé
que des réactions chimiques.
Mais ces réactions se produisent généralement
dans un fluide, disons de l'eau,
qui peut être en mouvement,
et avoir une certaine température.
C’est par exemple ce qui se passe dans les
sources hydrothermales au fond de l'océan,
dont on pense qu'elles ont pu être un lieu
possible de l'apparition de la vie sur Terre.
Pour essayer d'approcher des conditions
de ce genre,
on peut essayer de mettre
la réaction de Gray-Scott
dans une simulation de convection, comme
celle que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure.
Allons-y: j’ai pris une zone assez large.
L’image du dessus représente la température.
On chauffe par au-dessus,
on refroidit par en-dessous.
Je vois la convection se développer.
Et ensuite je vais saupoudrer du produit B.
Et regardez ce qu'il se passe.
Nos petites cellules se forment
et sont baladées dans le flux.
Tout ça est très joli
mais c'est toujours un peu court
pour dire qu'avec notre unique
réaction chimique
on a réussit à faire une forme de vie.
C'est une forme assez primaire d'homéostasie.
Ce qui serait bien,
ce serait de voir par exemple
comment le système réagit
à des changements de température.
Eh bien pour ça,
on va enrichir notre simulation
en se penchant sur les travaux
réalisés par Stuart Bartlett,
qui a réussit à pousser l'investigation
encore plus loin.
Dans les simulations que je vous ai montrées,
il y a une chose que je n'ai pas faite,
c'est d'introduire le lien entre les
réactions chimiques et la température.
D'une part on sait qu’une température élevée
accélère les réactions chimiques,
d'autre part certaines réactions
peuvent être exothermique,
elles libèrent de la chaleur,
tandis que d'autres sont endothermiques,
elles prennent de la chaleur.
Et ça va évidemment changer la donne.
On va reprendre notre première simulation,
sans le fluide qui bouge,
et pour schématiser, on va dire
qu’elle était à température ambiante.
Ce que je vais faire maintenant,
c’est la relancer,
laisser les petites cellules se développer,
puis refroidir la température par le bord
pour voir ce qu’il se passe.
Et regardez: le froid se propage
à partir du bord,
et quand la température devient trop basse,
les réactions chimiques se ralentissent,
et nos petites cellules disparaissent.
Le système n'est pas capable de supporter
une baisse de température:
il n'a pas de capacité d’homéostasie
vis à vis de cette perturbation.
Mais ce qu'a découvert Stuart Bartlett,
c'est qu'il est possible de légèrement
modifier le système
pour qu'il soit capable de justement
résister à des changements de température.
Voici l'idée:
au lieu d'une seule réaction
chimique A + 2 B → 3B,
on va en ajouter une autre similaire,
mettant en jeu deux autres espèces:
on va dire A'+ 2B'→ 3B'.
On a deux réactions de Gray Scott.
Il y a juste une différence essentielle
entre les deux:
on va considérer que la première réaction
est endothermique,
elle consomme de la chaleur,
tandis que la seconde est exothermique,
elle libère de la chaleur.
En quelque sorte on a deux couples
d'espèces chimiques
qu'on va essayer de faire travailler
en symbiose.
Je vais relancer la simulation.
Et voici ce qui se passe
dans les mêmes circonstances.
Les cellules se développent,
puis on baisse la température au bord.
Et là on voit que la production de chaleur
de la réaction exothermique prend le dessus,
et permet de conserver une température
raisonnable au centre,
et donc d’éviter la destruction totale
des cellules.
Et ça marche aussi dans l’autre sens
si on monte la température.
Ce qu'on a là, c'est un système chimique
relativement simple:
4 espèces et deux réactions,
qui est capable de créer
une structure dissipative,
autocatalytique et capable d'homéostasie.
Alors à nouveau, ce qu'on a fait ici,
c'est juste une simulation.
L'idée n'est pas de prétendre
que la simulation est vivante, pas du tout.
c'est juste de dire que si on arrivait
à faire vraiment l'expérience,
ça commencerait à être perturbant.
Imaginez, vous balancez quelques produits
dans une mare
et vous voyez des taches qui se forment,
se divisent, s'organisent, colonisent la mare,
bougent avec le fluide et même s'adaptent
aux changements de température.
Si on trouvait un truc comme ça
à l’état naturel
dans une mare de méthane sur Titan,
il faudrait peut-être commencer
à se poser des questions.
Malgré tout, ce qu'a estimé Stuart Bartlett,
c'est qu'il manque encore un pilier
pour prétendre qu'un système
comme celui-là
puisse être qualifié de vivant
ou du moins fasse partie de la "lyfe".
Si vous vous souvenez de l'épisode précédent,
j'y avais mentionné la définition
que la NASA donne à la vie:
un système chimique auto-entretenu
capable d'évolution darwinienne.
Il y a une chose qui en a fait tiquer
certains dans cette définition,
c'est la référence à l'évolution darwinienne.
Est-ce que ça ne serait pas trop spécifique
comme critère?
Trop centré sur la Terre, trop restrictif?
C'est aussi ce qu'a estimé Bartlett,
et dans sa dernière publication
avec son collègue Michael Wong,
il a proposé de considérer
une généralisation de cette idée.
Au niveau d'une espèce,
la sélection naturelle
c'est finalement un mécanisme
d'apprentissage.
Cela permet d'acquérir et de mémoriser
des données sur l'environnement,
et de les utiliser pour améliorer sa survie.
Mais la sélection naturelle n'est pas le seul
mécanisme qui permette de faire ça.
Une forme assez simple, c'est par exemple
ce qu'on appelle l'apprentissage
par association.
C’est l’idée de savoir établir un lien entre
un stimulus et un événement.
L'exemple typique,
c'est le fameux chien de Pavlov.
Si on fait sonner une cloche chaque fois
qu'on le nourrit,
il va finir par apprendre ce lien
et se mettre ensuite à saliver
dès que la cloche sonne,
même si il n'y a pas de nourriture
L’apprentissage par association,
c’est un des modes de fonctionnement
de notre cerveau au niveau neuronal.
Quand deux neurones sont stimulés
de façon conjointe,
le lien entre les deux se renforce.
Et ça augmente par la suite la probabilité
que l’activation de l’un entraine
celle de l’autre.
Alors on pourrait croire que l'apprentissage
par association est un truc super évolué,
réservé aux organismes disposant
d'un système nerveux très développé.
Mais en fait ça peut être quelque chose
de très basique, presque chimique.
Prenez le blob,
vous savez cet organisme étrange
qui a beaucoup fait parler de lui récemment.
Contrairement aux apparences,
il s’agit d’un unicellulaire.
Ca c’est une grosse cellule.
Et des chercheurs ont pu montrer qu'il était
capable d'apprendre par association,
et de comprendre et mémoriser un lien
entre la température
et la présence de nourriture.
Donc l'apprentissage, ça peut être un truc
plus générique que l'évolution darwinienne
qui semblait un peu restrictive.
De façon générale, Bartlett et Wong
ont donc proposé que l'on définisse
la vie au sens large, la "lyfe",
comme la réunion des 4 piliers
dont on a parlé:
Je vous l'ai dit, Bartlett a déjà pu
démontrer avec ses simulations
qu'un système simple pouvait posséder
les 3 premiers piliers?
Il ne manque plus que le quatrième:
l’apprentissage.
Je sais que c’est une des choses sur
lesquelles il travaille en ce moment,
et on aura peut-être l’occasion
d’en reparler un jour.
Affaire à suivre, donc.
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo.
N’oubliez pas de vous abonner
si ça n’est déjà fait,
de mettre un pouce et de partager la vidéo
si jamais vous l’avez trouvée
stimulante et enrichissante.
Les actualités de la chaine
c’est sur Facebook et sur Twitter,
et on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo,
à bientôt
– sous-titrage: Le crayon d'oreille -